deux épisodes se trouve une nouvelle
fois sur emilie ou un souper et laisser
professeur squeeze vous expliquer
souvenez vous c'est l'histoire d'un
livreur de pizza qui se retrouve enfermé
dans cette [ __ ] maison il ya des
monstres qu'il attaque est la dernière
fois vous n'arrêtez pas de mourir tout
le temps de la même manière au même
moment merci me dit je te baise parce
qu'en fait j'arrêtais pas de la fir du
regard alors qu'en fait il faut la
regarder et au bout d'un moment elle
disparaît tout simplement il ya
plusieurs monstres il y à milly il ya le
coulis à le pantin et yaki qui je sais
pas qui est qui qui met les gens dans
les commentaires disaient qu'ils avaient
kiki bref vous allez voir est en fait
voilà donc locateur ça c'est du mytho il
faut totalement la regarder guillen a
été là bas je vais aller voir et je la
regarde emilie
attends je ne voyais pas ça me faisait
peur la barre ah voila voila 2,1 me
tombent du plafond sécu c'est vrai pour
le père noël
rigole s'te plaît quand il va être une
heure du matin le cloud va rejoindre
midi et pour pas que le clou nous tue il
faut pas bouger ok et des fois les deux
peuvent arriver en même temps donc faut
regarder milliers pas bougé pour pas que
le clown de but et le clou on saura qui
est là parce que il faire bouillir
spéciales cos n'arrive je crois qu'ils
rigolent ils fait au fond pourquoi ces
temps là à temps mais là c'est pas c'est
une blague la lumière dangereux no fake
c'est une blague mec quecela max et
humblement bret stiles reste dans ces
deux pièces non mais qu on est d'accord
c'est pas du tout alu est ta gueule elle
est où allez vous faut la trouver elle
est là chenapan tu crois qu'on ne voit
pas [ __ ] est très calme toi c'est quoi
cette position et je te fait peur comme
ça non c'est faux emilie lâché en train
de me dire en fait pour arriver au
pourquoi il n'y a pas de lumière
mais c'est quoi écouter écouter les
enfants fait confiance aux professeurs
squeeze 1
je vois rien que ces [ __ ] de lunettes
j'avais même pas et cliquez sur
continuer en fait c'est compliqué parce
qu'il faut à la fois maintenir les
lumières allumées et toujours savoir où
emilie et pour pas les quitter du regard
wen mais quand j'appuie mais quand
j'appuie sur le clic gauche peu importe
où je fais ça touche de lumière ça n'a
aucun [ __ ] de sens au yard annoncé ma
lampe torche
ne jugez pas professeur squeeze à pour
allumer instructeur cee voilà [ __ ]
mais je suis trop débile regardez le
skills et allumez l'interrupteur pendant
que tu la regardes
romao non j'ai cru voir emilie quelques
ta gueule elle où elle est ou au lac aux
katas elle maintient dans une autre
pièce pour apparaître derrière et si je
crois pas que tu es un interrupteur
genre suivi la voile alors là je suis
bien là alors la mecque je suis
invincible contre emilie le clown
logiquement tour minuit c'est n'avance
jamais
mais pourquoi alors à zéro sur vingt à
binche qu'on voit que les parents en
fait je veux dire que dès que tu entends
son rire il faut aller la chercher pour
la voir en vue à aulas la même mais elle
se fait dans des endroits non mais c'est
improbable c1 pour la prochaine fois
elle va se cacher derrière une poêle
écho à la meuf but à cause d'elle je
fais des vannes moyenne
voilà merci emilie
à peine elle disparaît l'hérault la
direccte et je crois qu'elle a éteint
tous les nantais au coeur de la maison
j'entends des bruits
se dressa un
hôpital et où elle est où aller à chaque
fois tu fais la même technique va grosse
quéquette et kate et
oui tu es me dis oh [ __ ] toile elle
est en train de coin avec
aa taille se cachent de mieux en mieux
quand même là ohlala
oh c'est bon c'est bon première nuit
passée et là ça va être l'heure de
rencontrer monsieur clown est ce que
quelqu'un a vraiment envie de rencontrer
ici
personne tu as le clown yvette
terrifiant monga h et mardi j'ai peur de
loire
[Musique]
pourquoi messager ont trompé dans mes
calculs
paragraphe 60 caire c'est tout
effectivement ne pas se déplacer ou
bouger la caméra quand le cloud fait son
apparition ça fait rire damien ton
carnet
[Musique]
elle a même pas rigoler a tancé la
première minute de la nuit on se fait
déjà enchaîné par les deux [ __ ] on va
pas on va pas durer longtemps je vous le
dire mais on n'aura plus clown a alors
professeur squeeze et ses élèves sont
très heureux
auquel où elle est ou six usines juste
au tu m'as fait peur
je bougerai pas
attendez canon avec ce nom mais je pense
que tu as l'heure le clown y avait un
bug parce que peu bougé le regard quand
le cloud n'a pas été leur yeux un bug on
va voir ce qui se passe ayew l est où
elle fait peur elle avance vite encore
je crois qu'à travers ses débuts en fait
elle a pas dans une autre pièce elle
traverse les murs on va faire le test
avec le clown noir attends je bouge je
regarde protester
non il faut pas bouger le regard ayez
confiance en vos capacités monsieur
hochart et vous pourrez le faire soyez
moins dissipée en classe par les moins à
vos camarades et j'ai mis les mains en
l'air il peut pas m'attaquer
à sanaa le petit soupir qui dit qu il
s'est barré et wii puis là et
attend il enchaîne le gala elle est où
oh attendez challah il enchaîne mais on
est chaud hein attention on est plus
chaud qu'un parasol sur la plage parce
qu'apprendre avec professeurs squeeze
c'est aussi beaucoup d'humour beaucoup
de rires elle est où olala deux bouts et
où quoi la butte toujours plus de mise
en scène sa santé superficielle ml et ça
on sait tous
et
je suis mort emilie elle est apparue
derrière moi et le club aussi
voilà bah alors là non mais ça c'est le
combo de ftp mec tu peux rien faire moi
je suis professeur en sciences d'accord
à puce beghal c1 n'y a pas de facteur
chance dans ce que je fais un
doute je prends un malette et je me
casse aller à + alt ce genre de merde
oui mais voilà j'en sais déjà fin de
cette deuxième vidéo sur emilie moins
souple et n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça
vous a plu je suis désolé j'ai pas la
patience d'attendre h et enfin bon j'ai
pas la patience pour passer cette
deuxième nuit parce que pour moi quand
emilie et le clown apparaissent en même
temps l'un devant l'ot derrière bas tbc1
et ça ça me plaît pas ce quiz est fâché
sinon c'est un très beau jeu à doha pour
son prix suis content que vous ne l'ayez
fait découvrir et puis je vous dis à
très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien tu as to one piece
[Musique]
oh